we've been exploring how people wear
bags and interact with their personal
items in transit as designers we're just
as methodical as we are artistic because
we have to consider the way things work
and we also have to consider how things
look so there are research we found out
what the essentials would be of a
typical student of the things they need
to have on a daily basis and our
ultimate goal is to have those people
carry those items on their person to be
able to wear these jackets and go like
they should facilitate movement and just
doing things the research i work on
specifically is autonomous multi-robot
exploration and coverage so are the
research that we do is coordination of
multiple robots and finding out how to
coordinate these robots in order for
them to do tasks so with these are
what's the blue thing is a six laser
rangefinder so what it does it's a it
throws beams of light at 180 degrees and
we thought it measures the distance to
every object to them that amount and
then it takes that information and
that's how it starts building a map so
while we might need light to be able to
go into this environment particularly
something like a cave these robots don't
have that constraint how do these
different aspects coordinate to be able
to reach the complete the task that
you're trying to accomplish
you